And now it's time
for tonight's #HashtagWars.
(cheering)
Please welcome
this week's sponsor
that I am legally bound
to introduce right now,
Mr. Donald Trump.
-♪
-(cheering)
It's my birthday.
-It's not your birthday.
-It's my birthday, too.
It is definitely
not your birthday.
I want to sing,
♪ Deutschland, Deutschland
-♪ Uber alles. -No, it's not
your birthday. Stop singing.
Stop it.
It's not your birthday.
This is our...
Let someone else have a moment.
I have every moment.
I buy all the moments.
-All right, fine.
-(laughter)
This is our second-to-last night
with Donald Trump.
Uh, we wanted--
next week it'll all be over--
uh, we wanted
a chance to discuss
the truly important issues
with him,
as he is running for President
of the United States,
so that is why tonight's hashtag
is HowIWillFixEverything.
All right? Very educational.
Examples might include:
increasing funding for Zika
and other dangerous diseases;
-No. -or: deal with North
Korea's burgeoning nuclear...
-What do you mean, no?
-Unbelievable. Hold it.
I'm sorry, Chip.
Hold it right there.
Wha... It's the hashtag!
Listen to me, Chip Sajak.
I'll fix America right now
by changing that stupid hashtag.
-It's a very thought-provoking
hashtag. -No, it's not.
I want to prove
that I can do Internet puns
better than anybody--
especially your panel
of aging baristas here.
(laughter, groaning)
Tonight's hashtag
is something truly dumb.
Hashtag #FishTV.
FishT... We can't do...
That's ridiculous!
You're like a...
an extra-large baby in a tie.
I would hate myself, then,
'cause I hate babies.
I grind them up and then
snort them like cocaine.
All right, that's enough,
that's enough. That is...
The hashtag is #FishTV, I guess.
What are... what
would examples of that be?
Examples may include:
Golden Gills;
or: Don't Trust the Beach
-in Apartment 23.
-(scattered laughter)
-Isn't that funny?
-Well, the crowd loved it.
-(laughter) -So I guess
I have to put 60 seconds
on the clock, and begin.
-Johnny.
-To Catch a Predator,
Such as a Shark or a Barracuda.
-Yes, points.
-Excuse me. Excuse me.
-It's Artemis's turn.
-Excuse me.
You don't even have a buzzer.
-What?
-Blubber, She Wrote.
-All right, fine.
(laughter)
-Artemis. -Uh,
The Fellatio with Matt Lauer.
-(audience groans)
-Points.
-Uh, Johnny.
-The Fresh Fish of Bel-Air.
-Yes, points!
-(applause, whooping)
-Cheryl Hines.
-Um...
Carp Your Enthusiasm.
Yes, points.
Very good, very good.
-TRUMP: Excuse me.
-What?
-Excuse me. Excuse me. -Why
didn't you just get a butter?
You paid
for the whole (bleep) show.
-You couldn't buy a buzzer?
-I got a buzzer
and a butter, Chip.
-You son of a bitch.
-And let me tell you,
I got the butter somewhere
you don't want to know about.
Let me tell you,
I binge-watch this.
Sturgeon Things.
All right, fine.
Uh, Cheryl.
Stingray Donovan.
HARDWICK:
Yes, points.
-Excuse me. Excuse me.
-What?
The People Versus
Row Jay Simpson.
HARDWICK:
Fine. Points, I guess.
Artemis.
-CSI: Pacific Ocean.
-HARDWICK: Yes, points.
Excuse me, excuse me,
excuse me, excuse me.
All right. No one is even trying
to stop you at this point.
-Gill Street Blues.
-HARDWICK: All right, fine.
Gill Street Blues. Points.
Cheryl.
-60 Minnows.
-HARDWICK: Yes, points.